NEED THIS BED.
>> ♪ ♪
>> Tucker: STEPHANIE CLIFFORD
WHO PERFORMS NAKED IN ON LINE
VIDEOS UNDER THE NAME OF STORMY
DANIELS WENT ON "60 MINUTES."
THE RATINGS WERE HUGE AND SPIKED
111%.
SHE ALLEGED 12 YEARS AGO SHE HAD
A ONE DAY AFFAIR WITH DONALD
TRUMP.
THE WHITE HOUSE DENIES THIS.
CABLE NEWS HAS BEEN TALKING
ABOUT NOTHING SINCE OTHER THAN
STORMY DANIELS.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THIS?
EVEN IF YOU ASSUME THE STORY IS
TRUE AND YOU MIGHT, YOU HAVE TO
WONDER WHY IT MATTERS.
IF YOU ARE A TRUMP SUPPORTER,
YOU ARE NOT SO SURPRISED.
YOU KNEW WHO DONALD TRUMP WAS
WHEN YOU VOTED FOR HIM BUT YOU
DID IT ANY WAY BECAUSE YOU
UNDERSTOOD THE ONLY OPTION SE
UNDERSTOOD THE ONLY OPTION S
UNDERSTOOD THE ONLY OPTIONSS
UNDERSTOOD THE ONLY OPTIONS W
UNDERSTOOD THE ONLY OPTIONS WER
UNDERSTOOD THE ONLY OPTIONS WERE
PEOPLE WHO HATED YOU IF YOU ARE
A TRUMP OPPONENT IS STORMY
DANIELS THE BEST YOU CAN DO?
HOW ABOUT THE BUDGET DEAL THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP SIGNED?
IT DOES NOTHING TO PROTECT THE
COUNTRY FROM THE FOREIGN
INVASION.
THE PRESS IGNORED THAT.
WHY?
BECAUSE REPORTERS COULD CARE
LESS ABOUT VOTERS.
HOW ABOUT THE 16,000 AMERICANS
WHO OVERDOSED LAST YEAR AND THE
SHRINKING MIDDLE-CLASS?
THAT'S NOT INTERESTING TO THEM.
NOBODY IN BROOKLYN CARES.
TV NETWORKS DEVOTED THEIR
SCHEDULE TO CONVINCING US THAT
DONALD TRUMP IS NAUGHTY.
APPARENTLY AMERICANS HAD NO IDEA
THAT DONALD TRUMP HAD AN
OUTLANDISH PERSONAL LIFE.
IT'S NOT LIKE HE BRAGGED ABOUT
IT.
NOW IT'S CLEAR THAT TRUMP IS
FLAWED, THE MEDIA INSISTS THAT
AMERICA HAS AN OBLIGATION TO BE
SHOCKED AND DISGUSTED.
IF THERE IS ONE THING REPORTERS
DO WELL, IT'S SETTING A HIGH
MORAL TONE FOR THE REST OF US.
THAT'S WHY PEOPLE ARE ANXIOUS TO
TAKE IMPORTANT LIFE ADVICE FROM
TV ANCHORS AND PARENTS DREAM
ABOUT ALLOWING ANYONE IN CNN'S
PRIME-TIME LINE-UP TO BABY SIT
THEIR KIDS.
COME ON.
WHAT IS MORE SHOCKING IS TRUMP'S
PERSONAL LIFE OR THE
MINDLESSNESS AND THE DISHONEST
OF THE AVERAGE TV ANCHOR?
IT'S NOT A CLOSE CALL.
MARK STEIN IS AN AUTHOR WHO HAD
NEVER HEARD OF STORMY DANIELS
UNTIL LAST NIGHT.
HE JOINED US NOW.
I AM SURE YOU WATCHED EVERY
MOMENT OF THIS UNFOLDING SAGA.
WHAT IS YOUR VIEW?
>> WELL, I THINK THAT IT'S WHAT
IS IN THE MEDIA.
I AM AN OLD FLEET STREET HAND.
WE KNEW ABOUT SEX SCANDALS IN
THE U.K.
3 IN A BED.
AFFIXIATION.
I HAVE BEEN THERE AND DONE.
THAT I KNOW ALL ABOUT IT.
WHEN THIS THING STARTED AND
TUCKER, YOU MAY HAVE SEEN
ANDERSON COOPER ASKING ABOUT THE
MECHANICS OF THE ACT -- I WAS
THINKING, OH, THIS IS AN ACTUAL
SEX SCANDAL.
I WILL MAKE A NICE CUP OF TEA
AND SETTLE DOWN.
I CAME BACK AND THERE WAS A
PASTY BLOAT CALLED TREVOR.
THAT'S NOT EVEN AN AMERICAN
NAME.
HE WAS WITH THE FEDERAL ELECTION
COMMITTEE AND SAYING THAT
TRUMP'S LAWYER MAY HAVE
COMMITTED A CAMPAIGN ELECTION
CRIME BY GIVING STORMY DANIELS
$130,000.
MY GOD, IS THERE ANYTHING IN
THIS COUNTRY THAT CAN'T BE A
FEDERAL REGULATION INFRACTION.
I WAS SETTLING DOWN FOR A SEX
SCANDAL AND IT'S A CAMPAIGN
FINANCE INFRACTION AFTER ALL.
TO TIE IT ALL INTO THE SPEND
BILL, TRUMP PAID OFF -- IF IT'S
TRUE -- TRUMP PAID OFF A PORN
STAR FOR $130 GRAND.
THAT'S THE HART OF THE DEAL.
I WOULD LIKE TO SEE THAT TRUMP
WITH McCONNELL AND PAUL RYAN
LAST FRIDAY.
>> Tucker: I AGREE.
HOW DOES IT MAKE YOU FEEL TO
KNOW WHEN YOU WATCH CNN THAT THE
PEOPLE IN THE ANCHOR CHAIRS ARE
BETTER THAN YOU ARE AND THEY
WILL GO TO HEAVEN.
THEIR SALVATION IS A CERTAINTY
BECAUSE OF THEIR DEEPIDENCY?
>> THERE IS SOMETHING CREEPY
ABOUT THE MORAL CAR REASONING OF
THESE PEOPLE.
I DON'T KNOW A LOT OF POINTS.
THE LAST ONE I KNEW IS ABOUT 89.
I DON'T KNOW STORMY DANIELS.
SHE IS A USUALLY VESSEL TO CNN
AND THE OTHERS.
IN 2 YEAR'S TIME SHE WILL BE
PROBING
PROBIN
BROKE AND WANDERING WHAT
THE SWARMY LAWYER 22 WHOSE HANDS
SHE'S FALLEN.
THE PUBLIC INTEREST IS JOHN
EDWARDS, WHEN HE WAS RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT, GOT INTO THIS MESS.
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE'S
ARGUMENT WAS JOHN EDWARDS'S
FAMILY IMAGE WAS PART OF HIS
POLITICAL IMAGE AND WAS
REGULATED.
TRUMP IS THE OPPOSITE.
HE IS HOWARD STERN AND SHOW
GIRLS.
HE HAS MORE EX-WIVES THAN THE
PREVIOUS 44 PRESIDENCY COMBINED
AND DOUBLE.
HE DIDN'T HAVE A FAMILY MAN
IMAGE THAT FALLS WITHIN FEDERAL
REGULATION.
THIS IS GOING NOWHERE AND